all right
here we are i think we should be good
we've been having problems starting this
stream up it wants to start two streams
every time we
[ __ ] log into this program we're
trying to figure out exactly what it is
we're doing
annoying it's like i don't understand
with the whole thing with the key it's
like does it want the same keys want a
different key then i try to put a
different one in it's like no that's
still not right i don't know yeah can
you guys hear us all right it sounds
awful quiet
your sound is it well yeah but the the
video like the starter video that's a
totally different volume
different volume control than the
microphone is that's like on a totally
different
yeah you think we just started watching
a mandalorian
yeah we said that yesterday we got the
uh sophie sent us a
yeah bootleg blu-ray yeah it looks like
a factory
it looks like a factory disney product
too it came sealed and [ __ ]
exactly nice and even like real high
quality graphics on
on the [ __ ] on on the blu-ray disney
[ __ ] missed the boat by not selling
that on blu-ray
[ __ ] stupid um but uh we got done
with uh watch
episode one through three and it's
[ __ ] good
really good well that's what i had heard
i would have been very surprised if it
was bad because i didn't really hear
anybody criticizing at all that much
i did some checking and there's there's
another youtuber uh
go goes by the name victor van dumcock
and he dresses up like a [ __ ] space
alien and he gave out
new uh some brand new information it's
only like
he got it through personal sources
through disney and so it's only a few
hours old evidently
and it's good news for the mandalorian
they got they got approved up
two new seasons and they're gonna start
filming in the next couple days
out in some air force base out in the
desert um
lucas is involved in in terms of like
evidently lucas really loves it
and he's tutoring these other two
um directors they're gonna be involved
and they're gonna keep quality control
to make star wars
feel like star wars they want it to feel
kind of like the way the mandalorian was
gonna go
and they're gonna do kind of like an
expanded universe and they're
basically kind of getting rid of uh
getting rid of the that
that that trilogy they're not really
they're not going to really go in that
direction anymore they're going to go
more towards
the direction of like what the
mandalorians doing
evidently that everybody likes it that's
what i like and that's
that's what lucas liked so he's he's in
on that project as a you know
an advisor which is a good thing and it
could be a bad thing too i think
lucas is a great idea man he's not a
really good director
uh lucas is one of those guys you gotta
tell no
well he needs a good editor yeah because
lucas will put in some [ __ ] goofy
[ __ ]
and as far as i can tell so far
from the mandalorian what what i like
the tone of this better than the
original star wars
sequel because excuse me the star wars
trilogy
because it it's more serious it's got a
darker tone but it still has
comedic relief but none of it's wacky
and i like in baby yoda they have
something that's cute but not
obnoxiously so
yeah it's just cute and and you can
relate to it
and there's no silly music no silly
dialogue
um when when the mandalorian was
fighting the jawas
it had it was funny but it wasn't funny
because they were playing goofy [ __ ]
slapstick
music and [ __ ] and [ __ ] it was funny
because javas are just funny they were
just being what they were you know
but they're not making those funny
noises and trying to fight back and
throwing [ __ ]
and that's it out of the window don't
[ __ ] out of the window they didn't have
you didn't have to you don't have to do
much to make
a [ __ ] job funny in the way some of
the fights in like
indiana jones were funny yeah you know
what i mean you just let the jobless be
the jabba's don't play silly [ __ ]
music over it and don't like hey
this is funny yeah yeah look kids it's
funny you know you know
that that doesn't work for me well if
it's funny it's just funny
it's just fine like sign posts like
pointing it out
to me the tone so far has like been a
[ __ ] really good western
western and star wars is a western i
feel like that's what they wanted to get
back to
with this because this very much does
have like a western sensibility which
the original star wars did as well which
i really kind of like yeah it's a it's a
western movie with samurais in it and
[ __ ] wizards
that's what that's what star trek and
robots that's what [ __ ] star wars was
really i mean i heard well what i heard
when i looked up on the uh wikipedia
page i wanted to say before when you
were talking about the
seasons is i heard the second season was
supposed to be out
in october of this year and that they
were maybe also going to be filming a
third season
like yeah two have two more have been
all been approved
yeah i heard that they're already
working on them yeah so i think that's
the thing i heard that the second one
was already coming out
like in october that's what that's what
the wikipedia page right yeah
and i also didn't realize because i'm
watching it and i'm just like
i realized i was like well obviously
this is after
the you know the events of the first
trilogy because they were talking about
the empire being gone and [ __ ] like that
but when i looked it up on wikipedia it
said this actually happens
after it's supposed to be 25 years after
the end of the original trilogy and or
something like that and like
before like the force awakens the events
of the force awakens so it's like
between
there yeah you know what i mean like in
that 30 or 50 year period however long
it is like maybe somebody
yes sans remembers sandra's saying that
[ __ ] lucas likes dumbass [ __ ] like
laugh tracks to tell you idiots when to
laugh
and that kind of [ __ ] yeah that's just
like old school like [ __ ]
uh you know tv shows that had to have a
laugh track because
right they had to tell you what was
funny i guess it's like i don't know i
don't really get that
the best star wars movie really was
[ __ ] empire strikes back and lucas
didn't have that much to do with that so
the other people directed that and they
did a [ __ ] great job it's like a
classic war movie the way they
they had that thing and mango badger
also pointed out that um
the first star wars film i mean george
lucas's wife had a big part in
yeah editing that saved and edited
coming yeah saved and
i don't i feel like she doesn't get much
credit yeah and evidently his wife
cut a lot of like the silliest [ __ ] out
that there was a lot of silly [ __ ] in
there that was taken out
like real you know goofy robots doing
stupid [ __ ] and she's like nah that's
gotta come out
and uh you know that's lucas is not a
great filmmaker he's a good idea man
he's just not
not real good good movie well what i
liked in the mandalorian and like i said
we've only
um we'll probably watch the rest of it
later tonight
but um we've only watched like the first
three episodes so nobody like spoil
anything in the comments or anything
but one thing that i liked immediately
was that it was paying homage
to you know so it's like the jawas were
in it one of those like um little power
drawers one of the power droids like
that was like
like that they put them in there but
they didn't not in like a winky
kind of like hey look at this kind of
way it was just kind of like there
because it was there
you know yeah and it's you know and
shit's evolved a little bit it's a long
time after star wars it happened
yeah yeah i mean so all that stuff's
older or newer generations
and yeah i just i just think the tone
was
spot on you know and it wasn't afraid to
be kind of [ __ ] spooky
like when they showed where the
mandalorian where the mandalorians were
living they had that big mandalorian
[ __ ] skull thing over the damn
entryway you know what i mean in the
forest and
it was like yeah you know some darkness
to it
lucas wouldn't have put that in there
you'd be like why i think that might
scare the kids
you know what i mean well and i like
that then shut the [ __ ] up i like that
the main character is like a morally
gray character he's a bounty hunter
i don't want to scare her kind of like
han solo was he was a smuggler
he was not like a good guy but he's not
like a bad guy either he's just kind of
like
i'll just do whatever for a paycheck guy
yeah
the thing is though is that they changed
han solo when i saw it [ __ ] when it
first came out in the theaters
huh the first time you see han solo he
shoots a dude underneath the table yeah
and he shot
[ __ ] first all right and they changed
that later on they made it
it looked like greedo's shot first so it
looked like he shot himself it was like
what kind of [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] is that
the whole reason why
you liked han solo is because the [ __ ]
proves
from day one that he was dangerous yeah
so his conversion into being kind of a
good guy
was was real yeah he was a bad guy that
was his main story
right yeah you know he was but you know
was he a bad guy i don't really think he
was a bad grinder was probably going to
[ __ ] take him to the job of the hut
and they were going to [ __ ] do that's
what i mean
he wasn't a bad bad guy he's just trying
to survive he was just trying to survive
in
that you know context which is the same
thing that's happening with the
mandalorians
yeah i have to say too that i really
like
that i mean how amazing is it that they
have a main character
whose face you never see i mean i don't
know if you see it later but because
like i said i didn't do any spoilers or
anything like that because i wanted to
see it
um but you're showing they're [ __ ]
mowing out there again
they're always somebody's always got a
[ __ ] mo and it's always
that person yeah it's like i don't know
what the hell it is but it's like
and it's really really loud it's like i
don't know why they're just like right
our large service comes here [ __ ]
crack of dawn man
early in the morning well it's not early
to me because
we hired mexicans they come here [ __ ]
early they're going to do the [ __ ]
well they want to get the [ __ ] over with
before it gets too hot it's not too hot
yeah those good dudes are all from
[ __ ] tijuana
you know they know they know how to work
man these other dudes these people just
like get here and like get it over with
but no it's like four thousand degrees
[ __ ] heat working yeah [ __ ] god
damn yeah i don't i don't know how
they could do but that and like roofers
i don't like how do you not die i don't
really get it
but yeah so i really like the fact that
you never see his face
but almost from the jump you're on this
dude's side even though he's not
necessarily a good guy
you can't see him you can't see his
facial expressions
he doesn't talk a lot so he's almost
kind of like a mad maxi kind of
character but you can't like really
mad maxie that maxi pad but like you
can't really
you can't see his face so it's like
harder to relate to him but for some
reason
you just do for me it's
cr he's a cross between kind of like
um darth vader and [ __ ] um
uh dude from [ __ ] what
who am i thinking of clint eastwood yeah
like a clint eastwood and a darth vader
together which that's perfect perfect
for star wars yeah
yeah and i mean baby yoda you guys
and it's called the child the child but
everybody because because it's not yoda
obviously
but you know what i mean it's just i
kind of like like i said this is how you
do
cute because baby yoda is stupid cute
that is just stupid cute and the part
where
the part where the [ __ ] guy where the
mandalorian
mando i guess they call him that's not
his name but that's i think that's just
i think it's just
that's just what they call it for any
man that's not i can't remember what his
real name is it starts with a d
yeah i looked it up but um it's a it's a
weird star trek name
uh star trek name a star wars name but
um i like the one scene where he kind of
got
wounded and then baby yoda gets out of
his little
his little flying crib or whatever and
goes over there and like tries to heal
it and he's like
yeah and it's like the face that the
face that the baby makes is like really
funny because
even before i knew about this even
before the mandalorian came out
when uh pookie was little sometimes we
would
sometimes we used to call her lil yoda
because when you would pet her like
scratch her under the chin and stuff and
she'd make that little face like
and she looked like all little wives and
scrunched up like a little bitty yeah we
need to get it we need to get a little
child
costume for the [ __ ] cat i know it's
like now i was saying like i want a
werewolf costume now i kind of want a
baby
because she has a little baby yoda face
what they did with this series is
something that
lucas probably wouldn't have done or
couldn't have done
if you wanted the child to be cute yoda
[ __ ] yoda i mean
lucas would have jar jar binks the [ __ ]
out of it and he would think that was
cute
all right yeah no one needs to be jar
jar okay that's that's how it would have
been
or it would have had a [ __ ] funny
foreign accent he'd have given it a
chinese accent
it's not that well he's caught what it
is he's just he don't
he's just he is a man of his time i
guess
it's like he doesn't understand how
things are interpreted but you know
[ __ ] look i thought he was bad but
[ __ ] disney was worse
they're gonna have all these diversity
characters we're gonna have a black
character
but we're gonna make him the [ __ ]
janitor and we're gonna make him chasing
this white girl
and nah he's not gonna get her you know
it's just
they did the same [ __ ] [ __ ] well they
don't really think things
through they're not thinking it through
i mean it's better but they're not
thinking
we have to have all these diversity
characters but they're going to be
stereotypes
that's [ __ ] eventually went to what
you ended up with stereotypes
he's going to be like a he's going to be
the janitor
and he's going to be kind of like a you
know kind of like a clown
uh maybe we can get him to sing and
dance you know
he might look good with some white
lipstick on him that's
[ __ ] the way disney [ __ ] thinks
you know what i mean yeah see where
it's inclusion yeah you know they're
they're idiots
um so what they did with the child was a
totally different direction
the [ __ ] the little alien child is
like really low key and just it moves
real slowly and it just has a lot of
prolonged eye contact
yeah yeah and it just does and it just
does the ears just like
and it tries to help out and that's and
that's
that's all you need you don't need to go
over the [ __ ] top
well yeah like you said it doesn't need
to like run around like jar jar looking
at his ears flopping around
that's what lucas would have done that's
it's just like you know just
dial it back just dive dial it back yep
baby yoda doesn't have to do anything he
just has to sit in his little pod
yeah and like look at [ __ ] going huh
well the
the the comedian that's [ __ ] the
comedic element and the cuteness of it
was just
eye contact and timing how long they
showed it
yeah they would like something would
happen and then they would just
show it for just the right amount of
time and you go oh i see it yeah
like three or four seconds and then you
cut away
so can i just say i love this scene i
love the scene where the child was
lifting up that big like rhino monster
thing yeah and he's like
oh yeah and then he gets tired and he
goes oh
yeah and then falls asleep and he falls
asleep for like three days or something
like that
because it tuckered him out he's a baby
he's a baby
[Laughter]
that's pretty good though it's like for
a baby to have that much power it's a
good thing human babies don't have that
much power we'd all be [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] uh mangoes going that finn
could have been a great finn could have
been a great character i mean i liked
finn
as a character i liked all those
characters but
um you know i do see what you're saying
though those characters were only good
in the first half of the first movie
they started to go downhill towards the
second half
it just that wasn't star wars
just wasn't star wars to me it looked
like star wars the first movie really
did
the second one would just look like some
kind of chinese copy of star wars they
look like star wars chinese fan fiction
although i'm gonna tell you that
i hated that movie if i had to pick like
between
this most recent trilogy and the prequel
trilogy i'm going with the most recent
one
i really i really hated those prequels i
really hated them
i don't know a lot i i i i look back at
the prequels a little more favorably
than i used to
i don't well the thing is when i first
saw the prequels i was like oh those are
pretty good
but then when i saw him again later i'm
like nope they suck
i so so to me it's like they got worse
like over time
like because i tried to watch him like
not too long ago i was like nah i just
couldn't say
the best of the prequels was the third
one well yeah everybody says that
uh and really it was only like 75
percent of it
yeah clone wars was a mixed bag it was
like
half and half um the problem with the
problem with the very
phantom menace was that there was too
much of that kid
and that that kid was too young yeah
[ __ ] that kid and then they didn't show
enough of darth maul
and then they killed darth maul dumb
that was a [ __ ] dumb
you can't you can't introduce a
character that cool
no and then cut them in darth maul
should have been in all three movies and
killed at the [ __ ] last in
in in the third one uh and that that
character should have had a much better
arc
um you could have put count dooku and
all they could have had all those guys
in there
count dooku was kind of and then there
was that [ __ ]
[ __ ] forearm robot was the name of
that [ __ ] thing
general grievous general grievous
general grievous looked great it was a
good idea but it was just
too corny the
voice was basically you know
[Laughter]
and like some of the bad guys like the
techno army you know they have the
stupid voices and [ __ ]
too much what's up pope just want to
come around they're too many
stupid jim henson type voices yeah
which like that's fine in a jim henson
movie like if i'm watching a muppet
movie or labyrinth or something like
that cool do all the funny voices you
want
but you know try to keep it in star wars
trying to keep it doing well there was a
lot of [ __ ] stories about
what went on with george lucas back at
[ __ ] skywalker ranch while he's
making all that [ __ ] that
you know that he would have he would
have things
whole cgi scenes shot over and over
again
each time he's adding more and more and
more and more and then just
and not enough stuff and some more chips
and big
slimy monsters and more of this and
pretty it's just like a whole like
screen just like yeah
with all these more things have to
happen and when you look at some of
those like gun fights
there's a [ __ ] 500 dudes packed in
frame
each one's doing something and each one
each each person is doing something
that's ridiculous and
impractical and no way you know what i
mean like
one dude in the background shoots off
three heads of three different robots
within a second and a half
and then he falls and somebody trips
over him it's just obviously very
choreographed
and sped up nothing looks natural or
realistic in a lot of those fights uh
and i think it was in clone wars when a
lot of that just some of that [ __ ] was
just
very cartoony can i say that i really
did like the
robot in the mandalorian like the yeah
the bounty hunter room
yeah yeah the one he came like that was
kind that was funny too and that looked
like the way a robot would move
yeah i liked that yeah i mean i
liked that it wasn't like i'm sure it
was cg but it didn't look like it was cg
i don't think it was cg i mean it didn't
look cj if it wasn't wait it moved it
rattled and shook a lot i think yeah
like it looked like a crappy old like
crap which is cool that's what i liked
about the original star wars was that
everything looked like it was all busted
up and
you were just kind of using [ __ ] that
was like good enough because that's like
more realistic
way it moved it looked like i think it
might have been some kind of puppet and
i think they cg
a lot of control arms away so you
couldn't see what it was doing but it
looked rickety and it looked like it was
an object that was really there
and it it killed a lot of bad guys
yeah and i like that it was i like that
it was kind of funny like the stuff that
it said but not like overtly funny
yeah it was just like funny because the
situation was kind of predictable it
didn't move like a human it just did
things the way a robot would do it or a
machine would do it and that that looked
really cool
i think thought i was i bought into that
character
yeah and then it just kept wanting to
self-destruct and he's going don't
destroy yourself
yeah he's like no i'm standing right
here hold on guys guess what we got a
guest on
we got a guest i'm just gonna bring
little debbie on look at he's been to
sam's today
i'm so excited i got the [ __ ] pass
i'm gonna get him in
next time we stream we're gonna weigh
300 pounds
i haven't had oatmeal probably a long
time okay looking at it would you you
want to oatmeal pie boogie
don't get me wrong she probably won't
eat that okay this one's got several
cases of oatmeal pies
oh okay you can i'm not a huge fan of
the oatmeal pies
i've been having one of these in a long
time i like i like the nutty buddies
that we got
those are good i had one of those
yesterday that's them
i haven't had one and you said you got
zingers too right you got zingers too
you know what to say
they were cheap man well yes that's
cheap these things are better when your
microwave or at least they were yeah you
have you have the microwave
for how many seconds so they're all
vegetables shortening and sugar
it's all squishy i thought the inside
was marshmallow isn't it marshmallow
yeah marshmallow and it's all soft like
marshmallow see what it's like
mmm want to bite it's good yeah is that
something you know try to offer
something but she's like no i don't like
it i'm not [ __ ]
don't get all sensitive i'm getting
sensitive one i don't like to eat on
camera
too i'm not i just i told you right
before we started recording i'm not a
good fan of oatmeal
they changed it i mean of all the little
debbies like i
i like a bunch of the other ones better
than oatmeal
it's got a little bit more cinnamon it's
got cinnamon in it now
they changed it i think yeah it had
cinnamon before i think
she's trying to you don't want that look
your little face she's like that's sweet
i don't like that
she will eat like whipped cream though
yeah if you have whipped cream
or ice cream or something like that am i
plastic she's like oh
she loves plastic well she likes any
paper that makes noise when she steps on
it
like everybody's saying it goes crackle
crackle now uh
somebody said rogue one was pretty good
it was actually i think we saw that in
the theme yeah
was right i liked rogue one actually
that was the better of the new star and
um
i didn't mind solo either i saw solo on
uh
netflix a while back you know it wasn't
anything to write home about but it was
like it was a perfectly fun
serviceable movie disney should have
done a lando film
instead of solo yeah i kind of agree
with that they should have done
a lit because not a lot is known about
lando calrissy and the character
like we know a lot about hansel already
so i do feel like they could have kind
of
done more with that the the one thing
that i didn't really like about solo was
that
it kind of hit every beat it's like hey
here's how he got
this and here's how he got that it's
like it was almost kind of like a
greatest hits of han solo's life type of
thing
like all the stuff that had been
mentioned in the older movies like they
had the show
how all of it happened it felt a little
artificial to me yeah that's what i mean
so
i mean i liked it otherwise but it's
like that was one thing that did kind of
bug me i'm like
okay we didn't really have to know like
how that happened it's like not that
important
but yeah i do wish that they had done
orlando calrissy maybe it was just okay
it was better than the prequel and then
the
sequels i thought yeah
i don't know yeah i guess so but um yeah
i think that last one rogue one i think
was the best one
yeah the of all the uh recent ones
that very last one what was it called
uh the last jedi no was it last channel
wait that was the second one right
rise of skywalker right skywalker
they tried out they tried to fix that
[ __ ] as much as they could
the movie was long as [ __ ] and it got
ridiculous at the end
but they had to do something didn't they
yeah you just had to do something yeah
fido says you heard of the castle run
we're doing it now yeah exactly it's
like
we didn't need to see it it's like we've
already heard about it
it's like it's fine yeah it's better to
just kind of imagine that
and actually see it yeah that's like i
said that was the only thing that kind
of bothered me it's it because it seemed
like it was ground that had already been
tread you know what i mean so it's like
they could have done something
more interesting with his story like
rather than just kind of showing he's
like here's all the [ __ ] we mentioned in
the movie like now we're showing it to
you
it's that's the problem with them is
that they tried to make the stories i
think too big and have too many
characters in them lucas was having that
problem too
but yeah he wants to stuff as many
people into the movie as possible
it's like you can't concentrate on that
many people at once
if you look at the mandalorian it's a
small and simple story it's a lot more
effective
yeah and another thing that i like about
it too like i said i'm not sure
um you know because we're only three
episodes in but i like how
everything and it's really funny how
this seems like it would be
you know screenwriting 101 and actually
i think it is but a lot of movies don't
really do this
i like how each um action
leads to another action and it leads to
another action that leads to another
action it's like you know what i mean he
gets you know he finishes up the job he
gets another job that everybody's like
ooh this is a super super top secret one
and he goes to do that one and like he
gets in like a fight doing that and then
like the jawas take all his [ __ ] and
then like he ends up having to like
you know he gets the kid and then like
he comes back
and like all this there's like
everything leads to the next
thing there's nothing like superfluous
there's nothing
outside of it it's just like you said
it's a very simple story it's like
basically he goes he gets the quarry he
gets the child
and then he comes back and then he has
like a change of heart and decided he
wants to take it back and like you know
all this other stuff so
i was happy to see carl weather's in it
man it's cool
cool to see him and and i like the
because it's a smaller story
it has less characters in it so you have
more time with the characters yeah
she's
are and a lot of it can just be unspoken
yeah like watching him
fall off some [ __ ] and [ __ ] get
[ __ ] up and just going oh
man you know he's like yeah that was
[ __ ] up got mean then you
you just kind of get more of a feel for
the character but then you look at like
the new sequel trilogy i didn't really
get a feel for any of those characters
like
like like ray ray was in it
you saw a lot of rey but he doesn't
really know who that is
you notice that well like he's not
enough time there's not enough time to
like kind of
get into yeah her character because like
you said there's so much other [ __ ]
it's like maybe too complex so you know
what i mean it's like and i'm thinking
is this a robot maybe maybe ray's a
robot
well see the thing was is that remember
how in that story
she starts on this planet and you think
she might be a skywalker because there's
a bunch of hints
with the x-wing helmet and all this
other [ __ ] you think well
you know and then maybe luke had dropped
her off there or something
there's all this stuff that makes you
think that maybe she's important you
find out no she's not important she says
well she's kind of important
yeah she's palpatine's daughter you're
like what what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
just happened with this
you know what i mean they were just you
never really got to know who that
character was
you almost got to know who finn was
better yeah
well finn got more characterization yeah
and it reminded it was bad
and then poe his story arc
what the [ __ ] was that you know what i
mean like why was he in the movie
well the thing about it was that he was
he was supposed to get killed and forced
to
force awakens and i guess like audiences
responded well to him so they said okay
well we have to make sure that
he comes back so it's like i'm not
really entirely sure they knew it all
these
[ __ ] characters and none of them seem
to be any important you know
yeah and then you see like a legacy
character come in like luke or [ __ ]
solo and they kill him off or you just
see him a couple times and
luke's now a loser you know
losers on the island he's old and over
it drinking green titty milk
off a [ __ ] sea horse and [ __ ] sea cow
just
[ __ ] stupid you know you're like
who's writing this [ __ ]
[Music]
spider says i know people hate ryan
johnson's take on the second movie but
his other original movies are great
i loved knives out yeah as well i really
liked that yeah nice that was good
yeah he can't ride star wars though well
it just seems like that's really not his
baileywick it really does i mean from
watching knives out and seeing how
awesome that movie was i'm like this is
the type of movie that he wants to make
he likes
murder mysteries and thrillers and stuff
like that look at pogie she's getting
over here please don't
you're knocking [ __ ] over what the [ __ ]
yeah i think please don't i think they
went over there
i don't know what they were telling
these directors what i don't know what
they were
telling them to do either like you know
what i mean i think they were telling to
pack a bunch of [ __ ] in there it's gotta
have this and it's gonna have this in it
it's gotta have that in it because it
seems like they were just trying to
stuff
everything they [ __ ] possibly could
in each one of those movies
yeah it was just a [ __ ] a [ __ ] salad
you know [ __ ] from here and [ __ ] from
there and [ __ ] from over here and
just a big [ __ ] salad it's a [ __ ] gumbo
it's a [ __ ] salad yeah and i [ __ ]
love star wars
the only one i liked the only one i
liked was i liked force awakens i
thought that was going to be a good
start to it
it was not a perfect movie but i thought
it was better than the prequels
but then it was the last jedi came out
and it just kind of erased everything
from the first one and then the third
one erased
the other two so it's just like why are
you watching this [ __ ]
what are you doing you're just gonna
you're the star of the show now
that's ridiculous this is ridiculous
turn around say hi to everybody she's
she used to see her face her face
[Laughter]
she's trying to eat now she's trying to
fight she's trying to eat the she's
going to tear everything apart
the mouse and everything yes maybe we
got to shut it down
we should yeah we're going to show you
that she's going to next thing you know
she's going to turn around knock the
camera over
she probably will could with her little
butt because there it is her butt's like
right by the
tripod all right so anyway we're going
to watch
the rest of the mandalorian tonight
probably i think we have five more
episodes in season
one uh so we'll either come on tomorrow
and talk about that on the side tracks
or
uh shutter just added an interesting new
lion attack movie
which so we might watch that and review
it i don't know we'll see
oh we're gonna knock oh she knocked it
knocking [ __ ] off
and then she looks at it yeah well now
she's figuring out how to get down
it's not that far poke you can jump you
can do it glad yeah there's books in the
way
oh that's the book's in the way okay
come here come here i'll come here okay
[Laughter]
she cries yeah yeah right let's go and
go let's go all right so we're gonna
shut down we'll see you guys uh
tomorrow at three o'clock thanks
everybody for dropping by take my little
debbie taking this little we're gonna go
eat a whole box of little tips